[Musique]
cette image je n'aurais pas dû la filmer
la caméra de vidéo surveillance de la
mairie m'a repéré
deux hommes sortent
direction
le commissariat
la police a arrêté une journaliste
française qui filmait des militants dans
la région d'Ivanovo que s'est-il passé
[Musique]
dans la Russie de Vladimir Poutine
interviewait des opposants à la guerre
en Ukraine
n'est pas sans risque
[Musique]
dès le début mon statut était incertain
j'avais mon visa presse mais pas
d'accréditation sorte de permis de
travail pour journaliste le ministère
russe des Affaires étrangères n'en
délivre plus la France et ses médias
sont jugés inamiaux
[Musique]
accusé de propagande les médias russes
sont interdits de diffusion en Europe et
en Amérique les 27 États membres de
l'Union européenne ont approuvé la
mesure d'interdiction d'Arté France et
Sputnik Moscou mena son retour de couper
les chaînes d'information occidentales
pour les mêmes raisons il y a à Vignal
ville martyrs ou après le départ des
Russes des civils sont retrouvés
abattues dans la rue
accusé de crimes de guerre Moscou ni en
bloc et parle de mise en scène du
gouvernement ukrainien
depuis que Vladimir Poutine a décidé
d'envahir l'Ukraine le mot guerre est
interdit il faut parler d'opération
spéciale
toute critique de l'armée peut valoir
jusqu'à 15 ans de prison
dans ces conditions comment travailler
en Russie comme journaliste étranger
tant qu'on donne la parole aux partisans
du Kremlin tout va bien
à Saint-Pétersbourg j'ai rendez-vous
dans ce restaurant surnommé Le Patriote
barre ici la bataille de l'information
ferrages
[Musique]
un collectif chargé de défendre sur
Internet les positions du gouvernement
et d'attaquer ses adversaires comme le
président français qui a livré des
canons Césars à l'Ukraine
[Musique]
ces jeunes prétendent démentir les
fausses informations venues de l'ouest
et du crâne
nous indique qui diffuse des
informations
[Musique]
disons pas totalement juste sur les
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
et puis après nous nous signalons ce
contenu
moi je cherche les autres fils de
discussion avec qui nous pouvons
collaborer les chats patriotiques il y
en a beaucoup sur telegram surtout
depuis le début de l'opération spéciale
le groupe compte plus de 100000 abonnés
sur télégram la plupart disent
travailler dans le numérique
et venir ici à titre bénévoles pour la
patrie
on n'a pas
le temps on ne me dit pas vous devez
écrire 20 ou 300 commentaires si je peux
je le fais mais c'est pas toujours le
cas
comment
peut-on rester indifférent quand il y a
une guerre d'information contre la
Russie depuis si longtemps
tout le monde sait que les Américains
dépensent beaucoup sans se cacher les
lobbies de Washington les grandes
sociétés de relations publiques le fond
Soros
qui finance les guerriers de l'info
sont-ils tous bénévoles
et à qui appartient le restaurant
face à ces questions malaises dans la
salle
[Applaudissements]
cette journaliste a réussi à infiltrer
cyber front
elle s'est fait recruter sous une fausse
identité
sa mission cibler les opposants à la
guerre en publiant 200 commentaires par
jour
le travail est rémunéré plus de 800
euros par mois
dans son reportage elle décrit une armée
de trolls professionnels
très vite après publication
elle reçoit des menaces
on a fait comprendre que les soi-disant
chef de cette usine atrol préparé
quelque chose contre moi
du coup je ne suis pas resté chez moi
pendant une semaine je n'utilisais pas
mon téléphone
c'était stressant mais ça va rien de
grave n'est arrivé
selon la journaliste derrière cyber
front la l'ombrefghani Prigogine
un puissant homme d'affaires ayant fait
fortune dans la restauration
on l'appelle le cuisinier de Poutine
l'homme et surtout lié au groupe Wagner
l'armée de l'ombre du Kremlin
des mercenaires très actifs en Ukraine
en Afrique ou au Moyen-Orient
une milice accusée de multiples
exactions
[Musique]
l'oligarque est aussi à la tête de 195
médias spécialisés dans la
désinformation et la propagande
programme
le FBI l'accuse d'ingérence dans les
élections américaines de 2016
lors de son infiltration la journaliste
a eu affaire à un homme aux ordres de
prisme
la personne qui organisait le
recrutement et dans le bureau duquel on
travaillait s'appelait
[Musique]
par des sociétés connues aux États-Unis
pour être liées à Yevgeni Prigogine
[Musique]
travaillait pour glace 7 mix info
innovin faux trois filiales de
l'Internet Resort changement l'usine à
troll de Prigogine accusé d'être au cœur
de la campagne de désinformation en
faveur de Donald Trump
en avril dernier sur un autre site
internet appartenant à prix gojine
n'écrit love se présente comme
l'organisateur du mouvement
[Musique]
le patriote barre j'avais ramassé ce
ticket laissé sur une table
en haut le nom du propriétaire
le groupe Concorde
devghini privé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à cette offensive numérique
s'ajoute une répression accrue
pour éviter la prison la plupart des
médias indépendants se sont tu
quant aux rares opposants il aurait
interdit de manifester
en avril dernier la militante Olga
gorellique décide de braver la loi
était déjà sur place j'ai eu peur de me
faire arrêter avant même d'avoir le
temps de sortir ma pancarte elle était
dans mon sac mais j'ai réussi à la
sortir
mais j'ai décidé de le faire parce qu'il
le faut on ne peut pas rester silencieux
arrêtez elle écope d'une double amende
de 1200 euros dernier avertissement
avant la prison
Olga travaille pour une ONG de défense
des droits de l'Homme début mars son
directeur lance une pétition contre la
guerre signée par plus d'un million de
personnes dans les jours suivants l'ONG
est la cible d'intimidation
les caméras ont été recouvertes de
peinture on a eu beaucoup de mal à tout
nettoyer
ils ont tracé un V je l'ai recouvert
moi-même de peinture et par là un Z
Z et V de lettres qui s'affiche sur les
chats russes symbole du soutien à
Vladimir Poutine et à sa guerre en
Ukraine
l'entrée de l'ONG a aussi été aspergé
d'excréments
il faut être courageux pour faire ça
devant les caméras
que tu es protégé
un cadavre de chat est aussi placé
devant la porte
ils ont jeté de la merde sur la porte
mais tu as un animal c'est horrible
mais bon c'est comme ça on n'a pas le
choix
aujourd'hui l'ONG est classé agent de
l'étranger elle est soumise à de
multiples contrôles et risque de Lourdes
sanction
son directeur a fui le pays
depuis le 24 février plus de 16000
russes ont été arrêtés pour cette élevé
contre la guerre
pendant ce temps chez cyber front on
parle liberté d'expression et courtoisie
comme on voit souvent sur les réseaux
sociaux
peut dire ce qu'il pense nous écoutons
et nous discutons et c'est du dialogue
émerge la vérité
dans la petite ville de chouïa
autre son de cloche
sergueil vesteloff est informaticien il
sort tout juste de prison
sur les 12 jours j'en ai passé trois
dans une cellule minuscule d'un mètre et
demi sur un mètre et demi
je n'ai pas dormi pendant trois jours
c'était une vraie torture
il risque de retourner derrière les
barreaux son crime avoir tagué non à la
guerre sur la façade de la mairie
je l'ai fait parce que j'étais contre la
guerre en Ukraine parce qu'on a plus le
choix la liberté de manifester ou de
s'exprimer n'existe plus c'était tout ce
qu'il nous restait
[Musique]
c'est d'ailleurs en filmant cette façade
nettoyée que je suis repéré
ces fonctionnaires me contrôlent
et appelle la police
dans ce commissariat je suis longuement
interrogé sur le but du reportage
Sergueï l'activiste est aussi interpellé
libérez le premier il dénonce aussitôt
l'arrestation
[Musique]
je reçois une amende de 35 euros
motif officiel
journaliste non accrédité
les réseaux sociaux se déchaînent on me
reproche surtout d'avoir donné la parole
à un opposant la presse étrangère
continue de glorifier les collaborateurs
des nazis Ukrainiens combien de temps
encore les journalistes des médias
étrangers chiront-ils sur la Russie en
faisant la promotion des partisans des
uchronisés
[Applaudissements]
la vidéo de mon arrestation est diffusée
en ligne
[Musique]
et même mes papiers d'identité
avec mon adresse personnelle
un dernier coup de pression il est temps
de quitter la Russie
[Musique]
dans la ville voisine d'ivanovu j'ai
juste le temps de récupérer les images
d'autres activistes
[Musique]
sont poursuivis pour avoir distribué
1984 de George Orwell
ce roman sur l'enfer totalitaire et
devenu un symbole de résistance à la
guerre en Ukraine
dans les usines à trolls du pays jour
après jour les alliés du Kremlin refont
le monde
[Musique]
seul voie autorisée dans une Russie en
guerre où tout avis contraire n'a plus
sa place